مرحبًا يا بن، ما هو آخر ما يحدث
هناك على الأرض،
نعم أمبر، ما رأيناه طوال
اليوم هنا هو أنه كانت هناك
وابل من الصواريخ التي يتم
إطلاقها من غزة من حين لآخر، والمزيد من
الغارات الجوية الإسرائيلية تركز معظمها على
غزة هناك أكثر من غيرها
يتركز معظمهم في تلك المنطقة، وهي منطقة الشيخ
زايد جباليا
التي تقع في الجزء الشمالي.
نفهم من التقارير الواردة من داخل غزة
أن العديد من المنازل الخاصة قد
تعرضت للقصف ولم ترد أنباء في هذه المرحلة عن وقوع أي
وفيات هذا اليوم ولكن النشاط
كان مكثفًا إلى حد ما.  "لقد كنا نسمع
طائرات بدون طيار أه طوال فترة ما بعد الظهر عادة ما
رأيناه هو أن هناك هدوءًا في
منتصف بعد الظهر ومع اقتراب ضوء النهار من
نهايته، هناك عدة
وابل أخرى من الصواريخ تخرج من
غزة ولكن كل ذلك هو  يجري
أه كان هناك أعمال عنف في
الضفة الغربية في شمال مدينة نوبلز في
الضفة الغربية في مخيم بلاطة للاجئين
الذي يقع جنوب جنوب تلك
المدينة مباشرة، كانت هناك غارة إسرائيلية
أدت إلى مقتل رجلين هناك
حسب مصادر طبية فلسطينية
أه حماس أصدرت بيانا طويلا حول
ذلك وهذا مهم بمعنى
أنه في هذا الصراع الحالي ركزت إسرائيل بشكل شبه
حصري في الواقع حصريا
على ضرب أهداف
تابعة لحركة الجهاد الإسلامي حماس
إلى حد كبير بقيت خارج هذا القتال
ولكن  إنها لا تزال جزءًا كبيرًا من
المشهد بالطبع، حماس هي
الحاكم الفعلي للحاكم الفعلي لغزة،
لكن يبدو أن إسرائيل تركز كما قلت
فقط على الجهاد الإسلامي، والخوف هو أنه
إذا شاركت حماس، فإن نطاق
هذا العنف قد يزداد.  أكثر كثافة